because I've been watching so much of
your content I want to start right where
basically what I when I first heard this
I was like who said that and then they
said it was you it was something called
protecting your meat have you heard
about this protecting your meat and meat
standing for your money your energy your
attention and your time and basically
you've said that all relationships are
transactional and that meat is the value
that you're given to women so break down
what this meat is and how can men
protect their meat well the funny thing
when you use that phrase protect your
meat obviously people are going to think
you know what you know exactly but I try
to use that as a metaphor to say uh you
know try to show men where your value is
a lot of times people will give men an
ideal there's other things that are
included in this but it all boils down
to especially when you get to a point of
marriage what is your meat your energy
that you're going to put in typically
men give energy to women women pretty
much doesn't they don't reciprocate that
back I've never seen many men that spend
a significant time with women and then
come out energized even in the bedroom
most of the time they're gonna probably
fall asleep within 15 minutes but in
terms of attention if you remove any of
these things attention if you remove
these things you lose the marriage right
time time is a significant uh value for
men and matter or fact we call it and
also Napoleon Hill calls it your most
important asset and many men will spend
hours on hours on end to pursuing
relationships obtaining relationships
keeping the relationship alive and then
many times they will lose the
relationship if they stop giving the
time now the money part of it everybody
knows this all transactional you know
you've had girlfriends you've tried to
pursue women you're going to give up
money now it's not a bad thing that the
relationships are transactional so when
I say relationships are transactional
it's not a complaint many people think
it's it's a complaint but it's just a
reality and we have to accept that
reality gotcha have you so you've never
you've never seen coaches content ever
really I'm I'm aware of almost everybody
in this space kind of where where a
coach is at
um a lot of people I may have hear ideas
from other people but I don't think I've
actually sat down and watched anything
from like online I may have seen like
videos or like reactions to certain
people but I've never actually sat down
and said okay let me sit down and hear
him from my memory I may I may it may
have occurred in the past but for my
memory I can't like quote ideologies or
philosophies that he holds currently but
when you hear someone say all right
protect your meat and you're hearing him
break that down what's the first thing
that comes to mind to you it sounds good
you know like I think everyone should
protect their money everyone's a protect
their time right like I think that
sounds good it's just how is that
fleshed out that's what I'm just I'm
curious about right because I think
sometimes
um I what I love about
which you do so much Adam and I have to
shout out what you're doing is that you
bring in people from different sides you
know I'm really interested in you know
hearing more about your life I think
it's an interesting Dynamic mom and only
fans were you the one who sat down with
Ruslan I was okay so I I love what you
do Adam because what you do is you
provide an opportunity from different
people to hear a myriad of ideas I feel
like a lot of times people on the
internet sit in these silos right of
this one type of content one type of
information and so to me I'm very
interested in hearing all the unique
different ideas so that the men can sit
down and choose what is actually the
best yeah what is actually going to
tangibly improve people's lives because
to me that's all that matters at the end
of the day it doesn't matter if it's
from me or Greg or Adam rally if the
information makes you a better man makes
you a better father you may not feel
this way but makes you a better husband
if it makes you better that's the win I
don't care who it comes from and so and
so I love the ability of unique ideas to
being able to be discussed today and I
just hope the best idea always wins so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]